une toute nouvelle violent pour un
nouvel équipage un événement dans le
monde de laguiole pour laurent mas
charpentier de métier
cette réalisation est déjà une première
victoire et c'est son frère loïck membre
de la commission technique de la
fédération qui vérifie la conformité du
matériel
il ya des jeunes c'est la longueur et 10
m synchro la langue ayant respecté
maximum la longueur supérieure à celle
du mètre soixante insectes et après la
hauteur du milieu la largeur hauteur de
l'arrière ça varie en fonction du
constructeur comme en ce sens loïc
devant cette réalisation de laurent
satisfait plus afin de lier le sort tout
juste de l'atelier et faute de moyens
pour le moment c'est l'association
attentes qui prêtent une partie du
matériel
laguiole a été conçue pour être la plus
légère possible au moins 25 à 30% de
moins par rapport aux concurrents à la
fois très rapide comme j'ai dis donc
pour le moment c'est le processus est
bien parti sont peu habitués avec une
révolution mais celle là c'est parce
qu'il ya parce que c'est un projet où
j'ai réfléchi qui me tient à coeur
là on va partir justement essayer puis
retour on va gérer comme moi qu'aller le
maïs et ira on sait qu'elle sera
performante vont apprécier les hommes
qui devons être aussi performant
laguiole s'appellera lent mais des
beautés et la morale et couleur gris
blanc bleu de l'association si elle a
été construite est basé à fort de france
ce n'est pas pour autant la yole de la
capitale l'équipage sera même mixte
martinique ou à l'eau avec 10 coursier
de l'île seuls on a pris le temps de
nous avons des points
c'est un projet sur trois ans on va
faire une bonne compétition et être le
premier studio tu as été impossible il
ya déjà les options qui sont déjà là
avant nous mais on va pas être pour nous
non plus entre nous les avons notamment
de se positionner dans les cinq fois
mieux quand même
c'est quand même le sport national dans
tes et moi mon avis c'est pour un
sponsor c'est l'idéal de venir dans
l'ailleurs
donc je pense que pas beaucoup c'est
vrai que les sponsors ont du mal à se
décider
mais en retour je pense que le retour en
images et quand même est très important
appaloosa total éoliennes automobiles
sont engagées à hauteur de cent
cinquante mille euros pour deux saisons
mais d'autres sponsors seront
nécessaires le championnat démarre
dimanche prochain à fort-de-france et
laguiole de laurent mas sera sans doute
l'objet de toutes les attentions